our first date i just pitched her on
working for me
how did you meet her i met her through
bumble she told me she was the top sales
rep and i was like if you can sell we
can make a ton of money together and she
was like okay she's like i want to learn
how to market and i was like well i just
so happen to know how to do that
so i was like i'm gonna start this
company called gym launch and then she
was like whatever and the next time she
saw me i was like look you got the bank
accounts i got the corporate and she was
like okay you're like really doing this
i was like yeah i was like you should
quit your job and join me and she was
like i literally just met you i was like
yeah you should totally quit your job
and join me like i'm gonna go like fly
around the country and launch these gyms
and she was like ah let me know how it
goes and so i launched the first three
gyms came back she picked me up from the
airport i hadn't taken her date yet i
was like i will take you on the state i
promise as long as you do this one thing
for me first and she's like what you
helped me process these contracts and so
i had this stack of contracts that was
like this pie and we processed like 120
grand in like an hour and she was like
what do you do again